this is my favorite game because I
always play it yes are we reversing
roles yes we are oh my God am I getting
asked the final five
are you ready yes okay go I'm so excited
you love to dance in the rain so do I
what do you like to do in the snow
I like to watch my dogs run in the snow
there it is and most importantly I love
I keep the snow boots around and I keep
the um uh the ball scoopers and as soon
as it starts snowing me and the girls
dart
um and and we go to the quickest patch
of snow we can find and throw snowballs
love it that was the best answer that
was five answers okay uh no you're gonna
ask me a question okay okay
Worst Date you've ever been on the early
ones when I was like in high school I
went to a movie theater with a boy and
we were making out the whole time and
then he burped Doritos of my mouth
and I was like did you just burp Doritos
in my mouth and he was like yeah and I
was like we're done
we're done here disgusting he clearly
got too comfortable and he backfired big
time high school all right your turn
tough you're a pro
working since you were in diapers yes
diapers when's the last time you truly
got nervous at work today really yeah
absolutely me too really wait I'm
nervous every day but why were you
nervous which part I wanted to do a good
job and I cared about how it was all
going to function and you know would I
would I pull it off to my own
expectations and all of a sudden the
nervousness starts but I am not nervous
at all in front of a crowd I love a
crowd I feel so comfortable and safe
whatever I do to make myself nervous I'm
making myself spend about my own
expectations because if there were a
hundred thousand people in a room I
would feel so at ease and comfortable
with them what what about you every day
I'm nervous right now
[Music]
you can go and sing and perform in front
of thousands and thousands and thousands
of people are you comfortable then when
it's a bigger crowd I'm less nervous
I don't know why but like when I
remember I had to sing in my like high
school class with my like 11 people in a
class and my neck got bright red and
they're like something's wrong with
their neck
it's a panic attack thank you so much uh
yeah so when it's a big crowd I'm less
nervous because I'm like I can't see any
of you which was small it might really
bewilder most people they'd think the
bigger the crowd that's better oh my God
it's just a sea of that okay perfect all
right when was the last time um you were
hungover
gosh I don't it was so long ago I'm just
like I I stopped partying because I
wasn't very good at it I was like if I
drink if I drink a glass of wine now I
am gone shopping on Amazon so we'll like
have a headache in an hour and be like
here here it comes you know I'm not good
at one glass of wine and then the bottle
and then the next bottle and I would buy
the entire Amazon and you're not
hungover no of course I am I don't miss
hangovers at all so bad but I had so
much fun in my life and I'm I'm glad I'm
at where I'm at now and I'm glad I
experienced everything I experienced and
they're so pretty you know you're so
pretty and making changes you know
that's the big thing I think is whatever
you need to change the minute you do you
liberate yourself into the belief that
you have the capacity to do so and when
you don't change you keep the narrative
that you don't have you know the ability
or that you're weak and that leads to
self-flagellation so it's good to break
Cycles you're brilliant
[Applause]
why are you so smart okay tell me one
thing you love you absolutely love about
yourself right now
Ready Set Go that I had the ability to
change something that didn't work for me
and not be heavy about it and just do it
finally many years
finally occurred
wow
I'm in love with you okay okay
um what's the worst Christmas gift
um maybe you've ever received oh I just
talked about this on my podcast with my
brother working on it check it out uh my
mother sweet Mama
um I got we've always wanted a
trampoline me and my brothers because
we're like we jump out but we like
jumping um we always wanted a trampoline
and my mother she likes to do little
hints and she got me a uh one of those
like 80s like small workout Champs like
the personal trampoline right and so I
opened that up and started crying and
was like so you're calling me fat like
what I was like I'm in high school I was
like do you want me to work now like why
would you get me this and she was like
no no no it's it's a hint for the bigger
one and we were like what and she was
like go outside oh no and then we went
outside and saw the big trampoline
oh yeah you love that trampoline oh my
God it turns out I love the little one
because I would jump into my bed with it
every night it turned out great I want
to see that it was great who do you hope
to make proud
oh my daughters daughters love it kids
say that's all you care about who's had
a baby I'm like I hope he loves
everything I do
as soon as every choice I make yeah I
mean I I know we'll both screw it up
plenty along the way every parent does
but if you just fight to get it as right
as you can
you know I wish that I I mean really
every good change I've ever made is
attributed to my daughters I did I
wasn't enough for myself they were
what made it
um
necessary to change and I'm so like in
love with them and and in awe of what
they've inspired me to do because I
don't know when it's just used sometime
like it was just me and I don't care if
you pick other hood that is the best
life too people who are like it's just
so important to have kids if you don't
want to have kids that's great that's
awesome you're gonna have a ton of fun
like that's kind of fun either way it's
actually win-win for everybody whatever
path you choose I just had no idea that
I didn't Inspire myself enough to change
and grow at the pace that I've done so
ever since I've had my kids it was like
oh it's game time now now I got it now I
gotta do the work
oh that's so good okay all right
Riley's gonna be like
I just have one fear that one day he'll
be like did you have to talk about the
toilet so much you know
but whatever okay last one okay what are
you most excited about this year
uh I'm in baby making season so I just
be doing I'm trying to make a baby
so I'm exhausted just kidding I I'm in
love
um yeah I'm in love and I just want to
make babies I want Fuller them so I
gotta get going
I wish you the very best on your
insurance
I wish for all of your wishes I wish for
all of your wishes thank you
ah
I like
oh I'll go there
I can't wait to throw that in my face
I've always wanted a sister
will you date my brother
what's happening
I think we just got match made
us so young and fresh well we'll talk
after the show
I threw that one in there and and no
pressure because the question's for you
baby yeah okay
we'll talk after the show okay this is
the final question what is your favorite
music to work out to ah simple T-Pain
it was my high school girl that was like
my high school jam so I'm like let me
buy you a drink
you know
um by the way your body is the sickest
body ever you can't see it right now but
thank you so much I've been also like
lately you've just been out there it's
like you are so beautiful head to toe um
by the way T-Pain sent over a little
message for you check this out shut up
shut up yo what's up Meghan Trainor how
you doing it's your boy T Payne I really
really really appreciate all the great
things you've been saying about me for
all these years and I I I just want to
personally apologize for the phone tag
that we've been playing as well the day
that we get together in the studio and
the day that we make something special
is the day that we're gonna fuse
together and become a Megan Payne swirl
of some such I appreciate you you're the
greatest
keep being you you know we love you bye
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]